joining me now general Terrence R
Shaughnessy commander of the United
States Northern Command commander thank
you very much for joining me and I'll
let you get right back to work because I
know you have a lot on your plate I
can't even believe what you guys are
doing building these hospitals shipping
supplies I just saw you guys just
intercepted a Russian jet entering
Alaskan airspace and turned it away and
even sending soldiers down to the
southern border thank you very much and
just explain to the American people
everything you're doing well thanks
Jesse really appreciate the opportunity
to highlight the things that the u.s.
Northern Command and really our entire
Department of Defense are doing and you
started just right where our first
objective is to defend our homeland and
so we make sure that we have the force
that we need a hundred percent of the
time 24/7 365 even while we're in this
virus we make sure that we are ready
posture to prepare to respond to
anything we have that done we're ready
to go and at the same time we're
providing support all across the nation
because our nation needs us this is a
whole of nation approach whole of
America approach we're part of it we get
as you mentioned we got the hospital
ships we get army expeditionary
hospitals that are built up in the
Javits Center in New York City we're
doing the same thing in Seattle we're
bringing stuff down to New Orleans to
Dallas and we're postured to bring even
more we are part of this fight our
commander in chief has declared a war on
Kovac and we're treating this like a
large military campaign I know you guys
plan for everything but did you guys
wargame this thing out or is this just
on the fly well I'll tell you what just
the America wants us planning for the
worst things and that's exactly what
we're doing and and we've been part of
this all the way since the president
made that incredibly important decision
to restrict the flights from China and
we are part of bringing the American
citizens home and Quarantine mhmm
and some of our military bases and then
some of the folks that were on those
cruise liners we were able to house them
because American citizens needed us so
we're trying to stay one step ahead of
this we're doing the plan and we're
making sure we're gonna be there when
our nation needs us well we have a lot
of confidence in you guys and we owe you
a huge debt of gratitude it's just
astounding what you guys can accomplish
in such a short amount of time last
question
before I let you go I know this isn't
biological warfare you know we haven't
come to that conclusion the intelligence
agencies don't believe it is but
thinking ahead years from now our
enemies have to see that this really
brought this country to its knees are we
prepared for our enemies to put together
a biological agent that you can easily
sneak into the country just through
humans they shake a bunch of hands they
coughing on a bunch of people and then
here we are again shutting the whole
economy down how do you prevent that
well I think Jesse you've you certainly
hit an important point and I think as
horrific as this is this is going to
help America prepare for the future the
whole of America of approach is exactly
the approach and we haven't seen this
since World War two the way America is
pulling together whether it's a private
public partnerships whether it's the
interagency pulling together whether
it's a US military contributing right
here at home America always if they
stand up when they when it's needed
America will pull together and it will
do this whether that's something to get
after the köppen 19 or something that
comes at us in the future general thank
you so much for your service and America
thanks you well we appreciate you coming
on the air tonight